oh
jean boulet a la malchance pour tous qui
allait de travers dans ma vie
[Musique]
seul univers
j'ai trouvé
une véritable pièce porte bonheur
et si la chance c'était quelque chose
qui pouvait tenir dans le monde
et qu'est ce que j'ai fait
je les fais tomber dans les toilettes
[Musique]
ça fait tomber ma pièce par bonheur dans
les volets
tu viens de parler le peuple est il m'en
faudrait justin
[Musique]
c'est terrible se montrent pas
horriblement long
les humains n'ont pas le droit de venir
ici c'est une
terre de chance je partirai dès que tu
m'auras donner une autre pièce porte
bonheur il faut commencer par t'intégrer
match estime petit troll fraulein pied
jouer la nature on est dans le
département où l'on crée la chance une
drague c'est la seule créature qui
arrive à sentir la moindre ma chance il
est mal chance et c'est aussi chance au
dessus la malchance d'être la plus
infime quantité de ma chambre tu
pourrais arrêter toute notre opération
c'est dingue comme tu peux être
malchanceux
hyper méga malchanceuse tu va causer une
catastrophe
la connexion a été rompu
condamner tous les autres et une vie de
malchance et toi aussi
qu'est ce que tu fais ici
allez bonne chance à bout tout ça
vous fait quoi pour jeff
j'avoue que les monarques
[Musique]